president biden has not had much luck
lately inflation at record highs gas
prices also at record highs a migrant
surge at the border a crime surge within
the borders the first major war in
europe in 70 years approval ratings in
the doldrums and the progressive loss of
his ability to form coherent english
sentences
but yesterday
biden finally may have received a sign
that his luck is about to turn around
when a bird defecated on his blazer
at the center of our efforts to build a
future that's made in america
and that's not hyperbole it's about
being made in america
a lot of that has to do with this and
there it is there you can see it he's
talking and then this little white kind
of appears and we know what happened a
bird defecated on him the notion that a
bird defecating on you constitutes good
luck
is an old russian superstition based on
the sheer improbability of it happening
experts have put the odds at around 0.18
that's that's the the regression the
analysis has shown that it's that small
but it's not true
for everyone if you live in new york
city the odds increase to about 1.14
percent since new york is home to more
than 1 million pigeons and both of those
numbers are based on an average person
spending 5184 seconds per day outside
exposed to the predations of bird bowels
if you increase the number of pigeons in
your city or if you increase the time
you spent exposed to birds your chances
would increase even more if for instance
you locked yourself in a room filled to
the brim with birds and gave yourself
nowhere to hide your odds of getting
crapped on by a bird would be one
hundred percent which is why
i don't think joe biden's bad luck is
going to turn around
because joe biden's bad luck has not
been based on random chance
inflation is up in part because biden
and his party have printed and spent
money with reckless abandon and in part
because gas is increasing as well which
occurred because joe biden stifled
american oil production shut down a new
american oil pipeline and then gave a
new pipeline to vladimir putin which in
turn gave putin the opportunity to
invade ukraine which is causing oil to
spike even more causing massive domestic
instability which biden is exacerbating
by encouraging an historic flood of
illegal aliens pouring over the southern
border by refusing to enforce the law
which in turn biden and democrats are
also flouting throughout the rest of the
country by defunding the police and
letting criminals off the hook which in
turn is causing a historic wave of crime
that is now entering its third year in
other words
biden has made his own bad luck and it's
going to take a lot more than avian
excrement to turn it around
i'm glad you liked that clip now
ring the bell subscribe get those
notifications we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]